hey what's up you guys Denny here now
2017 is coming to an end
but thankfully we've got a lot of good
music to look forward to next year with
a preview of the music events and albums
to look forward to in 2018 we've got our
resident music expert miss Sophia may
seem so excited for next year because
there's a lot going on in the music
world what do you got for us there is so
much happening starting with the biggest
concert of the year with you know a
football game on the side the Super Ball
you know I only watch for the halftime
shows I mean I think I'm in that boat
but I'm and this year it is Justin
Timberlake which you cannot go wrong you
know excited about him but what
everybody wants to know is if there's
gonna be an instinct reunion I'm keeping
my fingers crossed on that right whether
it'll be a Janet Jackson cameo Jackson
yeah that's the other big one following
the whole controversy her team had told
us that she would be gonna do it if he
asked right that's right I don't know if
that's right a lot of people were
wondering though if maybe Janet has been
banned after that infamous wardrobe
malfunction back in the day the
Superbowl told us officially no there's
no band you know she's more than welcome
if that's what they want to do but they
are keeping all those details real close
to the bass side I'm hoping for the
NSYNC reunion no I'm holding out for
that I think they halfway yes
yes I so I think that would be a safe
bet I feel like the halftime shows such
a career milestone like Beyonce did with
Dustin Chou you're kind of looking back
at your whole career obviously wouldn't
be there without those guys and just
like Beyonce there's a precedent son
yeah another thing we're excited about
American Idol is coming back to TV I
mean I wasn't really asking for it yet
it was too soon but I think it's a
little too soon as well but now that we
have the judges panel set we've got Katy
Perry Lionel Richie Luke Bryan my boo
I'm kind of digging it I'm kind of into
it I think they're gonna have a fun
camaraderie it's not there's a good vibe
yeah yeah they definitely do I found out
firsthand I talked to them on the red
carpet and we have a good time take a
look at this may I may I just say just
stay tuned because I'm on the judges
panel with my other two cohorts here and
this let me say listen to what they say
to me that makes me turn 15 colors of
anything called blushing finals like her
dad
look down at him he's like yeah a lot of
there's a lot of rambunctious moments
between Luke and I and like and I go i
finals you're basically like how do I
get off of this show I mean I had such a
great career you guys try and compete
like one-up each other who can make
Lionel blush more we know we've done
that I got it down just learn the
trigger words that gave poor Lionel
really fun Lionel I think he's living
his best life I think and also on the
reality TV front the voice coming back
again for the spring this time around
Kelly Clarkson joining officially as a
coach from Idol like the original
American Idol no boys I love her though
I love her so much I think she was just
an advisor on this season so we got a
little taste of it she looks like she's
gonna be perfect addition to that show
we did get a little taste and she's been
on the show several times before I
thought it was kind of interesting that
once Idol said for sure it was coming
back they kind of made her look like the
bad guy like she was saying no to them
but she said that's not true she's been
working on the voice thing for a long
time it's been in talks for many years
and so is she
it was always gonna happen she's I don't
nothing you know obviously your career
in stem but she's been back there many
many touch she has has and you know Idol
still very close to her heart but I am
so excited to see Kelly on the voice
she's hilarious
no filter got a great relationship with
Blake I think people are gonna be really
excited to see that and we've also got
Alicia Keys coming back I really like
her on that show I like these four yeah
I think I like these four a lot I'm
really digging this panel for it yes
what else we got your biggest event of
the year coming up oh well Beyonce he's
gonna be there for sure so I'll let you
actually talk about that what are you
most excited about with be at Coachella
obviously this is her first big gig and
live performance since giving birth to
the twins I just feel like she's been
harnessing all this creative energy and
is ready to Alicia and I cannot be there
bells whistles and a leotard gonna be
gonna be epic come on me everything she
does is epic so I'm really looking
forward to that I mean yeah it's being
teased
a game-changing moment isn't that
actually after her Court choreographer
who said it's ended right amazing beyond
life-changing and a big game-changer for
sure here's what I'm holding out for
though she tends to like take the stage
for herself
I think Coachella be finally the place
where she brings out more people okay
surprise guest and coach tells the place
to do it you know it could be jay-z
Nicki Minaj does child I don't know it
could be at Kendrick Lamar I mean she'll
bring Destiny's Child out at Coachella I
don't know I think for sure at least G
J's gonna be the right he's gotta be
yeah but I'm I hope she brings up maybe
some people from lemonade like Kendrick
like Ed Sheeran they could do the
perfect duet they could oh I can't wait
so the twins Blue Ivy yeah come out
visit inna
like I'm just so excited what is okay
yeah myself what albums do we have to
look forward to next year so here's the
thing about albums nobody likes to
announce their release anymore everybody
kind of likes to surprise and if they
answer I know beyond thanks babe
you make my job real easy yeah no but
even if they do announce it it's only
usually a couple months ahead so here's
what we know January we've got Camilla
Kibeho solo debut coming out which I'm
so excited for and Fall Out Boy is back
with maniac this January after that it
gets a little dicey not not totally sure
but here's what I do know I do know
Keith Urban is closed on his new album
he's been working on it for a year I
know Jennifer Lopez is still working on
her all battling jovem right yeah with
Marc Anthony that feels like it's been
in the works before ever Justin
Timberlake also he's been teasing this
project with Pharrell for a very very
long time I think this is the year he's
gonna release it I gotta say between
Superbowl with JT and Coachella beyonce
I can only imagine that they are ready
to drop some new music so fingers
crossed actually you think it's time for
B to release me I think so okay I think
so and think about it she dropped
formation right before the Super Bowl
performance I feel like like she's all
about the announcement like that
respectable so I think next year's the
time
well that's why I think Justin is gonna
race one because why would you do the
Super Bowl without something new to plug
especially when it's a music performance
you know he's not gonna announce a movie
I mean he could but the JT is due for
some news
he's definitely do and we know that he's
been in the studio with Pharrell they
tease about it on social media all the
time so very very excited about that and
and I am gonna need a new album from Sam
hot it's time it's dance this is the one
thing I need you to deliver this year
it's been more than three years since
Montevallo came out
that's insane Inez has the biggest hit
of 2017 that's why here at the back road
he's nice to him okay I call your Sam
hunt and raise you a Christina Aguilera
I feel like she's also been sitting on
some news he has and she actually popped
up at the AMAs this past year I think
it's time for a new record girl
I interviewed Christina a couple years
ago on The Voice and she was talk she
had like multiple albums in the works
she had all these things she was working
on we have not heard any of it yeah so
I'm with you on the Christina thing I
would love to see that I have 365 days
to get some good music from all these
folks well we could speculate about
albums all day right oh my gosh so you
guys let us know in the comment section
who you are excited to get new music
from next year and thank you so me so
much for that nice little preview thanks
for having me of course be sure to like
and share this video and then come back
tomorrow because we're giving you guys a
preview of what's hot in TV and 2018
alright thanks for watching guys